[Música]
revista de prensa en directo américa de
france 24 ya estaba conmigo en el
estudio rosa pérez más de un rosa
bienvenida a buen viernes para ti vamos
a abrir entonces esta revista de prensa
el día de hoy con el caso de la
basquetbolista estadounidense brittney
griner que abre las portadas
internacionales tras su condena de nueve
años en prisión en rusia por entrar ese
país aceite cannábico buenos días raúl
exactamente y sobre todo las portadas
estadounidenses no abren por ejemplo
tanto el wall street journal como el new
york times destacan en sus portadas en
papel estas fotografías de antón nuevo
del esquí en que vemos a la
basquetbolista oyendo es su condena por
parte de la justicia rusa no y
precisamente sin embargo los titulares
están hoy centrados en el posible
acuerdo entre washington y moscú para
intercambiar prisioneros un intercambio
en el que se marcaría sin duda a la
basquetbolista y por ejemplo vamos al
titular del new york times' que dice la
condena a grinder pone el foco en el
intercambio como bien decíamos e
incrementa la presión sobre badén y
también el houston chronicle éste de la
ciudad natal de grandeur titular la
condena de grande no aumenta la presión
sobre biden también exactamente el mismo
titular que el 'new york times' y como
lo reseña rosa el medio estatal ruso rt
es el medio de este tal ruso como
siempre lleva un poco a la esfera
mediática la opinión no de digamos el
kremlin y dice que tanto serguéi lávrov
como antony blinken están dispuestos a
entrar en estas discusiones sobre el
intercambio de prisioneros eso sí que
tienen que darse a través de un canal
diplomático que acordaron biden y putin
con pocos detalles sobre este canal
diplomático porque de hecho rusia
insiste en que esta solución este
digamos diálogo tiene que pasar por una
diplomacia discreta y pide a washington
que pare de hacer esta diplomacia
pública y tan mediática bueno rosa vamos
a cambiar ahora el tema vamos a abordar
todo lo que tiene que ver con estas
influencers virtuales una tendencia al
alza en distintos países que ha muerto
ha vuelto a abrir todos los debates tras
un artículo que publicó la cadena de
informaciones tienen dedicada al
influencia turco diana ross y rosa cómo
funciona entonces exactamente estas
cuentas empezamos por lo que es el
ámbito tecnológico no de este
funcionamiento se trata de imágenes
generadas por computador cómo funcionan
pues los videojuegos o las películas no
sin embargo en los últimos años se han
venido usando estas tecnologías cada vez
más para crear precisamente eso
influencers y un ejemplo digamos muy
popular es el de esta influencers
surcoreana llamada rossi que fue creada
por estudio x en 2020 dice el artículo
de 'cien en que a veces los diseñadores
de estudio ex crean es su imagen de pies
a cabeza pero que otras veces cuando
hace de modelo ponen su cabeza sobre
digamos el cuerpo en movimiento de una
figura humana pero claro hay todo un
negocio detrás de todo esto exactamente
en relación a este modelaje entramos en
lo que es el ámbito comercial lo que hay
detrás de estas influencers virtuales y
es que por ejemplo rossi es una modelo
de publicidad online pero también
offline su imagen está en vallas
publicitarias
digamos del país y es que el director de
estudio x dice citado en este artículo
este año esperamos alcanzar alrededor de
15 millones de dólares en ganancias sólo
con rossi es imagen por ejemplo de
marcas de lujo como chanel y hermes pero
también de firmas de seguro y de bancos
que quieren llegar a un público más
joven además cuáles son digamos los
puntos positivos digamos en términos de
beneficios económicos y es que es mucho
más barata en cuestión de horas o de
semanas se puede generar un anuncio no
digamos a virtualmente con ella como
protagonista digamos en mucho menos
tiempo y invirtiendo mucho menos dinero
que para un comercial con humanos de
verdad no por ejemplo no se necesita
catering maquillaje y locaciones no
transporte exactamente por otro lado
también destaca a la sien a los
influencers virtuales nunca envejecen no
se cansan ni invitan a la controversia y
el creador de estudio x por ejemplo dice
lo que hacemos no es quitarle el trabajo
a la gente sino hacer cosas que los
humanos no pueden hacer como trabajar 24
horas del día o caminar en el cielo no
es humano pero si no lo dice eso
obviamente parece una persona de carne y
hueso y ahí está también una
controversia rosa efectivamente no y por
ejemplo en este artículo de 100 en la
citar a una joven de 23 años que comenzó
a seguir arroz ya esta influencer
virtual surcoreana pensando que era una
persona real en un primer momento rossi
la siguió de vuelta y a partir de ahí
surgió una amistad digamos virtual
incluso que perduró después de que la
joven supiera que rossi no era humana y
dice esta joven nos comunicamos como
amigas y me sentí cómoda con ella así
que no la considero una inteligencia
artificial sino una verdadera amiga es
tan bonita que no puedo creer que sea
una inteligencia artificial no y los
creadores defienden que la mayoría de
personas de hecho no conocen en carne y
huesos a las personas que siguen no a
las que admiran como influencers por lo
tanto que no hay tanta diferencia pero
otra controversia son también los
estándares de belleza no digamos a
promover unas ciertos estereotipos pues
sus súper inalcanzables de hecho no son
reales no inclusión de rol y son lijas
de una entrevista de ella exacto y vamos
a citar a dos de las preguntas que le
hacen por ejemplo le dice el periodista
cuéntenos más sobre usted ya dice soy
rossi y soy la primera influencer
virtual de korea o rossi es mi verdadero
nombre es un nombre koreano tradicional
que significa la única no es bonita jaja
tengo 22 años para para siempre y le
preguntan que quiere decir exactamente
con el comentario en su biografía de
instagram soy la única podría ser todo
el mundo dice soy una entidad que no
puede ser sustituida porque nací única
además como humana virtual tengo la
capacidad de estar en constante
evolución de prevalecer fuera del tiempo
y el espacio y ser lo que quiero ser en
todo caso me está dice que hay unas 200
personajes cuentas de influencers
virtuales en sus redes sociales y sin
duda trouble para resumir un poco esta
polémica es que para la influencers
digamos puede ser menos perturbante
estar bajo esta sobreexposición en redes
sociales pues digamos porque no tiene
una conciencia humana pero también para
nosotros puede ser incluso más
problemático y no aspirar o seguir una
persona que ni siquiera es de carne y
huesos si es problemático digamos
aspirar a ser una persona que no es uno
mismo y como lo dice es rosa y rossi no
es la única muchísimas gracias rosa por
esta revista de prensa hoy viernes feliz
fin de semana nos vemos el lunes con más
información y pasamos a saludar nuestro
primer invitado el día